- This is an Electrobat.
What's an Electrobat you ask?
Perhaps the love child of
Batman and a wall socket?
Or maybe a high-voltage vampire?
Actually, no; but it is
something equally surprising.
It turns out, New York City had
a fleet of electric taxis in 1895.
Yes, 1895.
(upbeat jazz music)
(gentle music)
At the close of the 19th century,
steam, gas and electric cars
were fighting for supremacy,
but electric was leading the pack.
Which is why a chemist named Pedro Salom
and an inventor named Henry Morris
built an electric vehicle called,
yes, you guessed it, the Electrobat.
Pedro and Henry took their creation
to the ultimate proving ground,
the hectic streets of New York City,
where they ended up part of
the Electric Vehicle Company,
the first cab company of its
kind in New York and the world.
The Electrobat was a hit.
There were hundreds of them
zipping around Midtown.
They had a battery station on Broadway.
People loved them because you
didn't end up covered in soot.
However, electric cars were almost twice
the price of their
combustion counterparts,
and they had a limited range.
So eventually the startup failed.
At the dawn of the 20th century
taxis in New York City were green.
But clean or no,
the battery just didn't have
the juice to win the day.
Perhaps they should've
tried out that vampire.
(laughing)
(soft electronic music)